[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
paul feinbaum is a man of his word
last week he was really busy we reached
out he said
when i am able to i will join you and
here he is
the voice of the sec the paul feinbaum
show
on espn radio paul thanks for joining us
if somebody was gone out of the country
last week and had no idea
what happened in college football how
would you sum up what's happened in the
last
seven days well simply put dan
everyone else is well everyone else was
already playing for second
now it's just not even not even a close
call
when this goes through and i think we
all assume it will
the sec has put so much distance between
themselves and the rest of college
football and i know in the past
a lot of people have accused me of
beating my chest unnecessarily i wrote a
book
six years ago entitled my conference can
beat your conference
i got laughed at um i'm not getting
laughed at anymore because it's yeah you
you just it's hard to explain
to those who don't swim in these rather
toxic waters of college football
the importance of adding texas
and oklahoma to what's already alabama
and auburn and florida and georgia lsu
and texas and i mean it's an endless
stream
of big brands and yeah i genuinely feel
sorry for all the other leagues because
when the big 10 starts looking around
i'll defer to you because i found out
during covert you are the big ten
you are the voice of the big ten
i i don't i i mean you you tell me who
uh who kevin warren's going after
because i don't see too many attractive
choices
well i wondered if the sec goes after
the big ten
i've heard that um and i it
it it seems unlikely today
uh because it's so hard to digest teams
uh
you know there's you right now the sec
is about to move from 14 to 16
and if you want to see everyone within
your five-year period in college that's
very difficult
but but i i i'm really interested to see
what uh
other schools want to do yeah i would
think if you're sitting there
up in ann arbor right now and jim
harbaugh is saying to his boss you know
we we really can't compete
in in the big ten i can't beat ohio
state so i tell you what why don't you
get me in the sec
where i know we can't compete not only
with
one team but probably a few teams there
but i wonder about this i i liken greg
sankey the sec commissioner to roger
goodell because he's running college
football
but if you said let's look at sankey's
endgame
in i don't know if it's a three-year
five-year period
are we looking at maybe an nfl model
of college football and greg sankey is
heading up
the top 32 to 40 college football
programs
and you just use the model that the nfl
has
very possibly and you know in until
whenever
maybe before covered we always looked at
mark emirate as the head of the
the ncaa uh i can assure you greg thank
you would take your call before you
would take mark emirates call right now
and and i don't mean that as an insult
to you i mean
i've heard him on the show many times
but i mean emirate is is really
powerless uh he's just
but he doesn't care he just you know
he's almost 70 years old he just cashed
a new contract in for 5 million dollars
a year whatever it is
so he's he's he's quietly going to uh
wherever former ncaa presidents go and
it's usually to be a consultant
but yeah that is exactly right and
it i don't if i could just say something
off the record
because i don't want anyone to quote me
on this but let's not forget who the
other partner is here dan
it's your former employee in bristol
connecticut i mean they
they have just a tremendous investment
in the sec
not only do they control most of what
the everything
of everything that happens outside of 2
30 or 3 30 on on saturday afternoon
they have the sec network and now
they're about to take over
the most valuable piece of property left
that's the 3 30 cbs window which
is not supposed to go into effect for a
couple years but something tells me
that might be expedited and they also
control the college football playoff
which we've heard a lot of double talk
recently
about why it may expand two years from
now or five years from now greg sankey
is also the key guy there so
all of this is going to start coming
together very quickly my former
employer your current employer espn well
i say that because whenever you go on a
program like the dan patrick show you
don't know if somebody has that
their finger on the on the nuclear
button that says you are no longer
employed
that's but if you want to get fired this
is the place to do it okay
oh and by the way i i if it if i go down
i would like to go down on this show i'm
wondering about
if you're usc if you're oregon
um how concerned would you be in the
pac-12 right now with what's going on in
the sec
well i think as long as the 12 team
playoff goes into effect reasonably
soon i don't think you're going to be as
concerned because you still have a
chance
now you know the first 12 team playoff
may involve 10 sec schools i say that
somewhat jokingly but
not really when you if you add i mean
with texas in oklahoma you're just
you're giving yourself more more wiggle
room and more room for era but
i i i think you know i've heard all
these you know big ten mary's
pac-12 all these marriages what what how
has that worked out for the big ten
uh i mean big ten fans can you uh can
you name
anything about rutgers or maryland or
nebraska i mean that exactly that hasn't
exactly gone over well
and and frankly most editions don't it's
hard to get the right school
in your league but you know nobody can
tell me these two are wrong for the sec
no and you know nobody care they wanted
the new york market with rutgers but
they don't care about
college football in new york uh
maryland they don't care about maryland
and maryland uh
nebraska nebraska used to be nebraska
but this global expansion that the big
ten had you're right it didn't work out
i was curious about oklahoma that in
let's say you expanded to 12
teams oklahoma in the big 12 was
guaranteed of playing
in the playoffs every single year and a
pretty
easy road as well as opposed to the sec
i know it's about money but i just
wondered about that
that part of this that oklahoma's giving
up that
you know the uh the fast lane to uh
play for a national title they are but
uh
you know it does matter what happens
during the season
and you know the oklahoma iowa state
game which i think was the big 12
championship game last year i mean that
just doesn't resonate
even though they're really good teams i
don't want to be knocking
some of the best teams in the country
but yeah one thing the one thing the big
12 never had
uh that you need nowadays is your con is
a conference network and i realized i
worked for one dan but the big 12 didn't
have that
and that really hurt them and ultimately
texas drives this
it has been driving this bus oklahoma
has considered the sec for about 10
years there have been back channel
conversation but remember 10 years ago
when college football was about to be
blown up
texas wanted to go to the pac-12 and the
reason
because they felt their academics
mirrored stanford's in california's
and schools like that and welcome to the
sec we
we we've got good schools here too uh
you folks in austin but
yeah things change and yeah i i hate to
sound like we're a bunch of
russian oligarchs sitting around uh
putin's black sea
uh palace but it's all about money and
and the money down here is just a lot
more valuable than the money out there
what do you do if you're clemson
wow you're i mean on one on one hand
you're
you're assured of your league but your
your brand has gone down a little bit
because
the acc has has some real issues i heard
over the weekend the acc was
was looking to expand and one of the
first schools they were talking about is
west virginia
now they turned their nose up at west
virginia 10 years ago dan and west
virginia had to hightail it
across the country so i mean you you'll
add a few schools but
you can't compete and i might say well
let me back up for a second
the biggest prize left out there is
notre dame and they're kind of
half in the acc uh but you know if you
notre dame
why do you why do you need the acc right
now you already have the benefit of it
in basketball you collect the money
there
and you play five games a year and and
you have your own tv network
it doesn't make much right now it
doesn't make much sense yeah i wondered
if there was a bigger play for notre
dame
if if you know it's musical chairs and
the music's still going and there's
still chairs available
i just didn't know if notre dame makes
it official and says
we're part of the acc well i don't i
don't have the authority to do that but
since i do work at the sec network notre
dame would like to join
the sec i'll go ahead and give the
invitation out right now on the damn
package
all right this just in mr scc paul
feinbaum
expressed an invitation to notre dame
okay
they just said yes okay yeah and and
and paul mccartney will sing the
national anthem at the first notre dame
alabama game yeah
this is wild uh could there be any
hiccups with oklahoma
and texas joining the sec um
i don't think so i mean this thing was
already down the track pretty far
uh when the news broke last wednesday
and as i'm sure you mentioned
thursday ironically right as jimbo
fisher was about to
get in front of the microphone and i'm
sitting there uh courtside we have a
setup and
i look over and there's the athletic
director at texas a m he's conveniently
available for comment too and and just
for the point
just for you uh trivia experts it's the
first time we've seen an athletic
director at sec media
days you know in only 11 years
well i that was one of those if you're a
m
it didn't look good that they just sort
of bypassed you
you know you know it's like monopoly
where you have
baltic and oriental and though like you
know you just kind of blow
right by them even though a m is a a big
time program
and has done well they just treated them
like on the monopoly board
uh we're already over here to boardwalk
and park place
hey we we loved you then so get out of
our way as we uh head to austin and
invite the longhorns and bevo into the
league yeah man
just made your job easier that's all it
did good
it did thank you buddy we appreciate
your time as always
dan it's always a pleasure thanks for
inviting me that's paul feinbaum
paul feinbaum show on espn radio and the
voice of the sec